[Music]
yeah
hey guys good game have fun
buddy oh sorry no time to play here go
fetch
now this is more like
[Music]
whoa
smells really good
we go
[Music]
oh yeah
hey it's Peter leave a message
Peter where are you
that's not working this is not cool I
almost got you
[Music]
surprise
what the hell
[Music]
foreign
just dropped me
how'd you find me you put a tracker my
suit or something I put everything in
your suit
including this heater
[Music]
that's better thanks
so the weapons I gotta take him down
take him down now huh steady Crocker
there are people who handled this sort
of thing The Avengers no no no just a
little below their pay grade anyway Mr
Stark you didn't have to come all the
way out here I had that I was fine oh
I'm not
here
thank God this place has Wi-Fi or you
would be toast right now thank goodness
while you're at it
look forget the flying vulture guy
please
just why because I said so
sorry I'm sorry teenager
stay close to the ground build up your
game helping the little people like that
lady a bunch of the churro
can't you just be a friendly
neighborhood Spiderman but I'm ready for
more than that now no you're not that is
not what you thought when I took on
Captain America trust me kid Captain to
lay you out he would have listen to me
if you come across these weapons again
call Happy
are you driving you know it's never too
early to start thinking about college I
got some pool at MIT
I don't need to go to Mr Stark is no
longer connected
awesome
[Music]